[Music]
telecom t1
the way there as they take
to the finals the most important match
of the most important tournament of your
life is not the time to change the game
forever
but the Rox Tigers couldn't resist it
when the stakes are at their highest
when everything is on the line
that's not the time to make everyone
rethink how they play the game fortune
doesn't favor
[Applause]
with one of the worst flashes
[Applause]
be done
the Roth's Tigers are one of the most
beloved League of Legends teams of all
time fans love them for their goofy
personalities their meta innovations and
for the fact that they filled a huge
hole left in the scene after the 2014
World Championship and let's get serious
for a second cacao bata so many more
names in the Korean League was left in
disarray after worlds 2014 most of the
league's biggest names went to China in
search of fat contracts leaving a lot of
teams to rebuild but in this turbulent
time for korean league a new hope
emerged
they came out of nowhere
dressed in unusual uniforms but they
were a group of team las' misfits the
players that Korea forgot dr. Tyler J
Peleg in the Newtonian and $200 is
really Wayne and a cutter honey so to
model mother ship is a Baku
starting at ad carry was prey a former
champion coming off an extended break
from the game now time to be meanwhile
top laner smeb was coming off of a
horrible performance in 2014 thanks Jeff
uncle this table tenant Elena very neat
about anything in fact of all their
starting players the only one that was
seen as world class was their support
gorilla so basically nobody expected
much from the Tigers but this group of
misfits took the lck by storm becoming
not only one of the best-dressed teams
but also one of the strongest but it's
just not enough frame popping over the
wall trying to get the autos down smeb
on a rampage through the enemy team
though but chaser moving forward has he
gone too far the answer is yes triple
killer spent quandra chill
exactly
the ribbon Pecha and smeb will lock up
the first pentakill of this season in
the game they were innovators they
invented strategies like jagger ma which
the whole world adopted will dominate go
down this time that's that flash being
down oh he gets a full absolute zero
that just really holds the team in this
choke point the damage now slows three
to four almost the entire team this
allows nice hits for piglets to come in
now diving Enix Mindy throws the
ultimate now it doesn't get much double
kill coming in for piglet now across the
wall still doing damages Phoenix piglet
is going for double lift and he takes
him down with the help of the minions
over the shoulder shot no look from
Phoenix takes down Zion Spartan and Game
two is quickly swept up by T play quits
but outside the game they didn't really
act like League of Legends powerhouses
they were a bunch of weirdos hey yeah
highway that's
but the misfit weirdos climbed the ranks
and by the 2016 lck summer split they
won their first title and now this group
of players that have either retired or
been rejected by other teams comes in
no big sponsor no big team house it's
not necessary because they are going to
lck summer and they are going to get a
spotted world to get tigers taken GG
it's about time but despite all the
Tigers success they didn't have one
weakness they just couldn't beat one
team a team led by the greatest player
to ever touch the game SK Telecom
the first Nexus turret down
down a triple jumper Lauren and SKT with
God with easyhoon takes the three Oh JJ
will see you SK Telecom looking to take
down the final Nexus turrets it does not
look good for Kuro and his team Koo
Tigers are falling SKT will be your
first ever two-time world champions but
with a full minute left and just like
that SK Telecom shows you who is the
best team fighting team on this planet
its SKT and they will win their third
Champions championship there goes the
Nexus turret there goes the Nexus TJ SKT
was in their prime they were in the
middle of proving that they were the
best team to ever touch the game the
Tigers just didn't stand a chance
SKT had everything the Tigers could have
ever wanted they had the big-name
sponsors they had the titles and they
had the crazy fan base who was dedicated
to them and would follow them anywhere
no matter where they played meanwhile
the Tigers were changing their team's
name every couple of months struggling
to find a single stable sponsor but
despite the Tigers track record against
SKT they were the world's only hope at
ending fakers reign some people saw them
as the only team that could possibly
beat SKT and stop them from winning a
third world championship
yes Rox Tigers will win the tournament I
think there's even a chance they don't
drop more than one game rocks were the
favourites heading into Worlds thanks to
their lck win but all eyes were on their
top laner because no-one was doubting
Smith anymore
stop sign and guca makes who comes up
here flashes in to the ninth face time
yet again snap gonna just turn it cold
or long convergence can throw down still
finds the kill gets the shield and the
stud on the lira does he go for it man
he's gonna do it but he hasn't hunted
deep up I have to play really cautiously
and carefully goes back into the bays
dive fire babe showing why he is the
best operator in the world fighting for
breath my baron taken taken nice maron
spent stumble baron going after ygor's
turning around
believable spirit steals med usurped
faker as the best player in the world
some absence on telling daddy Rebecca
dog Azumi money hopefully champion see
before eating ha
cool but despite these off the
expectations and epic titles the Tigers
stayed true to their goofy selves at
Worlds
[Music]
but once they actually started playing
things got a little messy
[Applause]
just took down the rock
now
[Music]
[Applause]
just took down the
the Tigers got their [ __ ] together by
the end of the group stage and by the
quarterfinals they were looking
unstoppable Saira just below down to
that side of the mat Marillion still
coming as well that's the yellow orb on
your screen coral able to get away not
for any any summoners and here's the
rest of ember gaming has hello here's
the Rio game - Bevers already picked off
make that three Koro
doesn't even need this knife a double
kill for Kuro in the mid lane for Rox
Tigers no now he's in the danger zone
this could be enough and now it's still
gonna be the one picked up nicely played
by Kerr to get away gonna lose his life
as well and that is the ACE for one
beautifully played by Rox Tigers they'll
be taking this series three two one as
the turrets fall it's gonna be the
rematch of world's last year Rox hoping
to get revenge on SK Telecom t1 as
peanut is the best singer in the world
Rox Tigers back on farm pumping to win a
World Championship for many fans this
was the real grand final the defending
champions versus the upstarts the only
team that had any chance of beating them
look for who it has that are only so
many objectives this world our products
are palatable
game one ended things weren't looking so
good for the Tigers so they pulled out
their secret weapon one they've been
saving for just this moment you can get
to spectres cap but when we're told who
has that's the pushing lanes they
actually have done an insta lock miss
horseman really weird seat by this point
at Worlds Zyra
was a priority pick her oppressive
laning and insane damage meant that if
she was open a team was basically
guaranteed to pick her I do think that
what's what is strong about siren now is
that if you go past thirty five minutes
you have to mid laners in terms of
damage so the Tigers let SKT have her
and instead they flex their creative
muscles and ran an ad carry a support
leaving SKT stunned and dazed
[Applause]
[Music]
they can play safe and play aggressive
arrows teleports be damned who cares the
to on to kill for the rocks bottom play
beads I rock poke you outrage it and
they even got to pick up on Bank rocks
doesn't actually to stop pushing right
now they can delay the recalls Cheryl's
[Applause]
he's going to the church they go for the
minions are gone and it's too much
SKT are here to defend is a difficult
freebie to pushing town to topple off
thousand hold back on towards prey push
back yet again but sparing whoa break it
what's integrated are you gonna do Jake
you need that's tiger chasing me chewing
gum oh you don't think I can I thank you
Dan and as she was pushing to have a
couch on a job
the Tigers were one game away from
seizing their destiny one game away from
slaying the god of League of Legends and
becoming the new kings of the game but
faker wasn't interested in giving up his
drone no he's there's way too much
damage looking for favor getting shot up
now its member the back side but he
can't find much to do it still Rox
Tigers waited to plan the door opening
could be it's a to preserving two three
four zero has the box blow up even more
and this could be the game-winning play
right now Carl's got nothing left to do
sure you pop the guardian angel but what
does it even matter
it's a-440 it's the eighth it's the game
SK Telecom t1 bringing us to game 5
watch Barrett Barrett the Nelson is
alive but no split right now for begging
it won't be up in time but they don't
know 2700 but he can't be given we will
fight it's gonna be all apologies
bang and it's a-440
[Applause]
[Music]
Banky getting the kill again as they
move are the Nexus turrets and it's all
there zero for this one
t1
backs against the wall bang himself 300
against rocks Tigers in the series and
as Goethe
just their third world final the Tigers
were knocked out of world by SKT for the
second year in a row and to make things
worse they had to watch as their rivals
lifted their third summoner's Cup from
the side of Mines
when they come and open the whole quad
from Daytona my little absolute I was
about to volunteer on deck and the
saddest part was that it was the last
World Championship that the Tigers would
ever play as a team the roster disbanded
by ahead of the 2017 season with all
five players going to different teams in
the lck all the creativity and ingenuity
in the world couldn't keep these guys
together especially when other teams
were offering far more lucrative
contracts but in their final act of the
Rox Tigers the team gave fans just one
last gift the satisfaction they've been
waiting so long to see
already dead
we three down looking for four there is
do Cruz's guardian angel the Tigers
pushing Porter for what might be the
final push of the game will they get
their revenge for whirls begging the
last met alive he is gonna have his
guardian angel pop he's gonna revive
from it but not for long he is taken
down in the rocks Tigers rampage through
the SK Telecom pays to take their
revenge and to take a trip to the grand
finals tomorrow the Rox Tigers came
together as a misfit but they left the
team as a legend they never quite
conquered the world but their goofy
antics and brilliant strategies made
them fan favorites because they could
never resist being different there's no
other team quite like the Rox Tigers
they were just a group of friends who
weren't afraid to challenge convention
they didn't look after play like the so
called a legends of the game they
climbed up from the very bottom of
league of legends and they nearly made
it to the top laughing the whole time
and no one ever made a winning will
quite so fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]